this i thought was super interesting
tell me if you've seen this mark oh yeah
love this okay so this is more plates
more dates he was covering this girl
i guess she's a tick talker she started
filming herself and she blamed this guy
of being a pervert because he literally
the guy that works there too
you just did this you'll see him and she
edited the video in a certain way i'll
play this first she said blew up in her
face she's accusing me yeah the black
guy who's standing up in the background
not the one who's lifting yeah she's
accusing him just to clarify because
it's hard to see even what the [ __ ]
she's talking about mm-hmm but i hit him
with like perving on her yeah and when i
stand up for myself he threatens to call
the police and revoke my
membership
so she edited this video and slowed down
here
what's she saying so this guy turns and
she put the subtitles oh damn when we
don't know if you said that
do you need something
[Music]
okay i thought so
jesus christ lady sucks
[Music]
keep the question
keep it keep me pushing she thinks she's
all hot
so i saw this video as well this is
actually the video of her the entire
video um this is ray william johnson's
tick tock this was handled so poorly
trainer gets caught on camera being a
pervert and when i stand up for myself
he threatens to call the police and
revoke my membership
do you need something and he's like
what no she's such an [ __ ]
but it's also not like she's a 10 either
right
she sucks
his knees like my grandma
okay
all right and it's girls that aren't the
tens that are always like
people are hitting isn't that outrageous
okay i understand that women have to put
up with a lot in situations like these
but the video doesn't show anything more
than a glance and then we get right into
do you need something to then blasting
their face on the internet and calling
them a pervert
pointing out that she slowed the footage
down so this look is actually yeah he
must have just done that yeah yeah she
might have she added the caption oh damn
when clearly his mouth is moving way too
much to have said oh damn he's talking
to his friend mid sentence when he
turned around now i don't know if these
dudes were checking her out or not but
as someone who makes videos when you set
up a camera and record yourself in
public people stare doesn't mean they
want to [ __ ] me or maybe they do want to
[ __ ] me i don't know this was handled so
poorly so more more plays more dates is
like
just like all of us if we saw like a hot
girl of course
this girl's but that's it no she's just
looking for an intention calling him a
pervert but by the way yeah don't just
shoot somebody for that that's something
that's that's the shitty part yeah i
mean it's defamation but then also
like
she's obviously looking for attention
yeah
hey sweetie i hate to tell you yeah
there's real hot girls who really get
gawked at the gym hey
you're not one of them yeah yeah you're
you're la-4 you're a young brian callum
as a girl okay and i never i wasn't
getting she's not bad but i mean she's
all right
young brian
yeah
i was you know what when i was her age i
wasn't bad that's what i got she's all
okay everybody i know big deal i'm dead
lifting you see my ass like whoa there
are still
[ __ ] when you watch a gym in miami
you're in l.a oh my god like a bridge
troll yeah she sucks